Odpovědné computing se chápe
jako vývoj quantum computingu
s vědomím jeho síly
a potenciálních dopadů – když říkáme odpovědný,
myslíme tím vývoj a používání technologií
na základě předem definovaných principů, které nám pomáhají předcházet
možným škodám a zmírňovat je
a zároveň podporovat řešení, která jsou proaktivně
inkluzivní a zodpovědná – v IBM
nás pocit odpovědnosti vůči
společnosti pohání už desítky let – dnes se nazýváme katalyzátorem,
který pomáhá světu fungovat lépe – to znamená, že
máme odpovědnost zvažovat důsledky
technologií, které vytváříme a pomáháme uvádět do praxe
při vývoji této nové technologie
rozhodnutí, která dnes přijmeme, ovlivní budoucnost
a tato rozhodnutí
mají potenciál mít obrovský dopad na společnost
například možná budeš muset rozhodnout, jestli chceš vyvinout aplikaci,
která pomůže jen pár zainteresovaným stranám, nebo
tu, která by mohla vyřešit společenský problém
doufáme, že ty jako klient budeš schopen přemýšlet
o odpovědném vývoji quantum computingu –
odpovědné myšlení může tvé firmě pomoci vybudovat důvěru
u investorů a zákazníků
a zároveň budovat pověst integrity
a respektu u tvých zaměstnanců
a klientů – na druhou stranu
ti může pomoci chránit se před negativní publicitou, pokutami
a sankcemi – v tomto videu
ti představíme důležité úvahy o odpovědnosti,
které můžeš probrat se svým týmem
při průzkumu quantum computingu
a jeho aplikací – pokud jde o quantum computing,
odpovědné myšlení a jednání
znamená řídit se souborem principů
a hodnot, které tě vedou při vývoji
a nasazení technologií
například to znamená být transparentní
jak ohledně omezení, tak ohledně možností
quantum computingu – dnes máme jazyk
ve svých smlouvách, který po klientech IBM Quantum požaduje,
aby naše systémy používali odpovědně
a aby naše systémy nepoužívali
k nekalým nebo nelegálním účelům
tyto klauzule nazýváme
klauzulemi odpovědného a přijatelného používání
tento jazyk už ovlivňuje to, jak naši klienti přemýšlejí
o vývoji quantum
pro jejich případy použití – můžeme také
ovlivňovat směr quantum computingu
tím, že se rozhodujeme, které aplikace budeme rozvíjet
a akcelerovat
abychom se chránili před potenciálním nezodpovědným využíváním
naší technologie, vyvinuli jsme také robustní IBM Quantum
bezpečnou technologii – když přemýšlíš o tom, jak
a k čemu quantum computing využívat,
mluv realisticky o svých očekáváních
od quantum computingu a o časových horizontech,
ve kterých doufáš quantum začlenit
neprezentuj quantum computing
jako záhadný – raději se ho snaž vysvětlit realisticky
jako počítačový hardware,
který se řídí pravidly kvantové fyziky
ujisti se, že tvůj případ použití pro quantum computing
je proaktivně inkluzivní
a bere v úvahu všechny potenciální zainteresované strany
k určení rozsahu
případných negativních společenských dopadů
ujisti se, že máš jasně definované principy
a hodnoty pro průzkum svých případů použití
a vývoj – díky
za sledování – doufáme, že
až budeš přinášet quantum computing do světa,
budeš také přemýšlet o tom, jak to dělat odpovědně.
The the